très bien
[Applaudissements]
non y'a plus de mons il se fait je sais
je sais je sais cyril jeu viril oui je
ne déciderai paszek n'y aurait personne
autour de 7,2 cette bande j'ai été
fébriles
ils étaient faibles j'étais attiré par
quelque chose que tu ne peux pas
comprendre j'étais attirée par l'argent
d'autres
[Rires]
outils seront tirés j'avais toutes vos
questions si je suis j'éprouverais
fabien
whissell a tu
triches et m'as tu trahis
quelle est la suite de notre relation
fabien
doit-on faire un break
doit-on acheter un break
il est que saute avoué
un peu pardonner non non non mais sinon
on perd 10 j'ai toujours
fait avouée à moitié pardonnée
si ça marche pour les p ça ne marche pas
pour les foot n'ont pas bien il tout oui
dis nous ce que tu as à dire qu'elle
avait fait tout à l'heure j'étais sur
mon ordinateur et j'ai essayé d'écrire
quelques blagounettes heureux
quelques-unes de ces fiches et mon
téléphone a sonné je soutiens guillaume
s'intéressent enfin au bas peuple alors
je décroche et qui comme le dit pas bien
il paraît que tu dès dvd ben je lui dis
oui ça me touche je dis s'intéresse à
moi c'est autre chose qu'à raqqa numéro
de téléphone pour lui et là il me le dit
pas bien écoute moi bien je te prends
une bd ses instincts menteur il paraît
qu'il s'est dit fuck with on l'a dit une
hausse de 10 une bd et je te donne et tu
me donnes le numéro gagnant joli mais
depuis quand tu veut animer ce prime il
m'a dit surtout pas je ne veux surtout
pas animé rango service en supplie et un
mot ce numéro et gilles et marie blais
c'est bon vous en avait trop dit
le coupable
ça reste lyon faisant tomber oui yahoo
genton votre sanction avec l'air
[Musique]
cachez divisé par deux
jusqu'au 16 décembre
si vous lui donniez le prime oui
oui la descente n'est pas même quand tu
seras du temps limité
et on va donner
l'autre moitié à moi à une association
l'association de son choix
et vous allez
alors animé le prime non
gratuitement oui
you
saint gobain
[Applaudissements]
animateurs du prime de jeu du soir
seront moi même et dont j'entends
[Applaudissements]